[Music]
every resort town in the US has a candy
store but one store in his mo Beach
California goes beyond the usual taffy
and caramel apples if hot licks has its
way Americans will be snacking on
everything from caterpillars and
cockroaches to mealworm covered apples
Larry Peterman is a candy man on a
mission
for more than a decade he's been
promoting a valuable food source that
most Americans find revolting in a land
of plenty people resist Larry knows why
from an early age parents teach children
to avoid insects in our culture from the
time that we're really small we're
taught to avoid insects they might bite
you like a mosquito I don't got a good
just got a good cricket in it but kids
aren't the only ones munching on bugs
around the world more than 1,400 insect
species show up on menus insect dating
or entomophagy is part of healthy diets
in Asia Africa Australia and Latin
America this trend is anything but new
archeologists have found evidence of it
dating to the earliest humans advocates
of insect eating like to note that it's
environmentally sound producing a pound
of Caterpillar takes 1/10 of the
resources needed to produce a pound of
beef
and insects brim with vitamins and
minerals but despite all the benefits
most Americans can't stomach bugs
welcome welcome welcome ever seen
unlike Larry Peterman who celebrates
them at his dinner party gentlemen the
evening begins with Larry's version of
the classic shrimp cocktail
we're just finished preparing a cricket
cocktail it's a lot like a shrimp
cocktail Paulie instead of shrimp will
use crickets okay folks here's the first
course now enjoy
is it surprising while you're enjoying
this I'm going down and get your next
course the main course is a stir-fry a
special garnish here we go
dinner is served I can't get ready okay
go three go several courses later Larry
presents his piece de resistance here it
is folks what you've been waiting for is
now don't anybody dive in until
everyone's reserved please we call them
a Pismo surfer what it is is a banana
with whipped cream and a really good
cockroach on it you don't have to eat
the wings you don't have to eat the head
unless you want to do you know oh you
know where this cockroach has been we
could do another one next week if you
like Larry predicts he'll eventually win
people over as we become more and more
insect food oriented our tastes going to
change and so I see a niche for somebody
that does gourmet insects
could have some snob appeal like people
taste wise I mean this is good with eggs
ooh this bug is good
you